So, Sean, before we get Will in here to really screw things up, let's go ahead and let's introduce the show. Oh, do like a little thing like that. Yeah. So, I mean, so I'll take this one, right? Because everybody can do it really smooth, right? Yeah, go. Hey, welcome to SmartList.
所以，肖恩，在我们把威尔叫进来把事情彻底搞砸之前，咱们先来介绍一下节目吧。噢，弄个那种小开场。行。那什么，我来开这个头吧，对吧？因为每个人都能表现得很顺畅，对吧？行，来。嘿，欢迎收听《聪明糊涂虫》。
We've got a great show coming up. This isn't a jazz, it's not a jazz show, though. It's more of like a comment. Well, hey, welcome to SmartList. It's pretty good, but it sounded a little too Arnett. Oh. Can you take some Arnett out? Okay.
我们接下来有一场精彩的节目。但这可不是个爵士乐节目。更像是一个评论。好吧，嘿，欢迎收听《聪明糊涂虫》。这挺不错的，但听起来有点太阿奈特了。噢。你能把阿奈特的感觉去掉一点吗？好吧。
Hey, welcome to SmartList. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart.
嘿，欢迎收听《聪明糊涂虫》。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. You know, I've been listening to the podcast and it's not terrible. Welcome. It's not terrible. Will, you're doing great. Thank you.
是的。聪明。是的。你知道的，我一直在听这个播客，还不算太糟糕。欢迎。还不算太糟糕。威尔，你干得真棒。谢谢。
Sean, we knew you were going to be fantastic, but Will, I got to say, you're doing really, really, really good work. You seem to be in a real slot. The voice sounds great. The questions are always snappy. Sean, you're providing incredible leadership. Let me ask you something. Go self-assessment.
肖恩，我们知道你会表现得很出色，但威尔，我得说，你干得真的、真的、真的很不错。你似乎进入了一个绝佳的状态。声音听起来真棒。问题总是那么简练。肖恩，你展现了令人难以置信的领导力。我问你个问题。来个自我评估吧。
Go self-assessment. Just quickly, Sean, hold on to that question. I've got issues with myself, but I feel like a lot of it can be re-recorded, so I don't feel so bad about it. Did you listen to the show? I have listened to the past couple, and it's not terrible, as I said. What do you do when you're listening to it? Are you driving or are you at home?
来个自我评估吧。简单说，肖恩，先保留那个问题。我对自身有一些意见，但我觉得其中很多部分都可以重新录制，所以我感觉没那么糟了。你听这节目了吗？我听了过去几期，正如我所说，还不算太糟糕。你听的时候都在干什么？你在开车还是在家？
I'm driving and I'm giggling and looking kind of psychotic at red lights. I've listened to it as well when I'm driving and I've gone, and then I hear somebody say something, and I think, oh, it'd be really great to say this right now, and then one of us says it. I had that same thought. I was like, oh, boy, I wish I would say something. And then, boom, I said the exact thing, like, huh, I guess my brain works the same as it worked like a month ago.
我在开车，一边傻笑，在红灯前看起来有点精神失常。我也在开车时听过这节目，当时我想，然后我听到有人说了一句话，心想，噢，这时候说这句话可太棒了，接着我们中的一个人就把它说出来了。我有过同样的感受。我当时想，噢，天哪，我真希望我说点什么。然后，轰，我说了完全一样的话，就像，哈，我猜我的大脑运转方式和大约一个月前一模一样。
I don't need to play it back because I was there. That's the way I was thinking for, like, all the way up until a couple of weeks ago. How about that? Yeah, I was stuck in some real traffic, and I was like, huh, let's find smart lists. And then I got a little embarrassed because I pulled my car in a valet guy took it, and the smart list thing was on my radio thing, and I was like, uh-oh, this guy's good. I did the same thing. I listened to it.
我不需要回放，因为我当时就在现场。直到几周前，我一直都是这么想的。怎么样？对，我当时被困在车流里，心想，哈，找找“聪明糊涂虫”听听吧。然后我有点不好意思，因为我把车开进代客泊车区，代客泊车员把车开走了，而收音机屏幕上还亮着“聪明糊涂虫”的界面，我当时想，呃-哦，这家伙真行。我也做过同样的事。我听了。
How do I change this? I did the same thing, and I pulled in, and I thought, oh, my gosh, and I ripped my phone off, turned off Bluetooth, clumsily, and I'm like, please don't, you know. People are going to love us or hate us for talking about how much we love ourselves right now. I didn't say I love it. I just said I'd listen to it. So all right, so we, is it Justin Baton?
我怎么把这个关掉？我也做过同样的事，把车停好后心想，噢，天哪，然后我猛地拔下手机，手忙脚乱地关掉蓝牙，心想，求求你，你知道的。人们会因为我们现在表现得这么自恋而爱死我们或恨死我们。我没说我爱听。我只是说我听过。所以，好吧，我们，是贾斯汀·巴顿吗？
No, it's Jason. It's Jason. God. It's Justin. I know. You know, a lot of people do make, before we get into your guests, one thing I do want to say, people do make that mistake of, I've been privy to it where people go, Justin, I'm a big fan, right?
不，是杰森。是杰森。天哪。是贾斯汀。我知道。你知道的，很多人都会犯——在我们聊你的嘉宾之前，有一件事我确实想说，人们确实会犯那种错误，我曾亲历过有人说，贾斯汀，我是你的超级粉丝，对吧？
I mean, it happens quite a lot. It happens about once a week. Why do they not know Justin? I think it's a combo between my name and my sister's name, Justine. Right. Justin, well, I think you've called me Justin a half dozen times. That's not true. That's not true.
我是说，这种情况发生得相当频繁。大约一周发生一次吧。他们怎么会不知道贾斯汀呢？我觉得这是我的名字和我姐姐的名字朱斯蒂娜（Justine）之间被搞混了。对。贾斯汀，好吧，我觉得你叫我贾斯汀大概有半打次了。这不是真的。这不是真的。
I did say, when you got your, Jason got his big star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame a couple years back. And they misspelled? It says Justin Bateman on the show. No, you're joking. I am joking. It's written in some. He is joking.
我确实说过，当你的，杰森几年前在好莱坞星光大道上获得他的巨星时。他们拼错了吗？上面写着贾斯汀·贝特曼（Justin Bateman）。不，你在开玩笑。我是开玩笑的。上面确实刻着一些。他是在开玩笑。
But I did say, when he asked me to say a few words, I was amongst a few people who said a few words, and I did say, you know, I remember, I said the first time I really took notice of Jason was years ago, I was watching Family Ties and I see Justine Bateman and I said to myself, man, I wonder if she's got a brother. See, I have zero recollection of that because I was in such a blackout during that ceremony. Like that's a crazy. It was fun. It was fun for us.
但我确实说过，当他请我说几句时，我是为数不多说几句的人之一，我确实说过，你知道，我记得，我当时说我真正注意到杰森还是在多年前，我正在看《家族羁绊》（Family Ties），然后我看到了朱斯蒂娜·贝特曼，我就对自己说，天哪，不知道她有没有兄弟。看，我对那段记忆全无，因为在那个典礼期间我宿醉得太厉害了。那感觉太疯狂了。那很有趣。对我们来说很有趣。
And the girls were, your girls were there and you're in Amanda and just all you bunch of friends. It's an honor. It was neat. It was definitely cool. And we were able to celebrate you. Yeah. You know, it was nice.
你的女孩们也在场，还有阿曼达，以及你们这一大帮朋友。这是一种荣幸。那很棒。绝对很酷。我们能为你庆祝。是的。你知道的，这很好。
I did not want Sean there because he was on the list and you crossed him off. What was the thing? And I showed up, but they kept me behind the barriers and they kept you behind the barrier and then you got arrested briefly. It was close enough. It was close. Okay. Wait, wait, wait.
我当时不想让肖恩去，因为他在黑名单上，而你把他划掉了。那是怎么回事？我去了，但他们把我拦在栏杆后面，把你拦在栏杆后面，然后你因故被短暂逮捕了。距离够近了。很接近了。好吧。等等，等等，等等。
We are liquid last thing. Where is it located? It is on Hollywood Boulevard. I believe it is east of Vine on the north side of the street. I've not been there since since the ceremony because I'm no driver. You never do a drive by with your with your darkened windows. You never do a drive by a nice track. I told the driver to slow down a little bit about next time I get real sad.
我们说的是液体最后那家店。它在哪儿？它在好莱坞大道上。我记得它在藤街（Vine）东侧的北边。自从那次典礼后我就没去过那儿，因为我从来不开车。你从来没开着你那贴着深色车窗的车去兜风吗？你从来没去那儿踩点吗？我告诉司机开慢点，下次再去我会觉得很难过。
I should just go there and just sit crisscross apple sauce on it and we know where to find you. Oh my God. It goes missing. We know where he is. Yeah. Just fill the bucket a little bit. Hey, gang.
我应该直接去那儿，盘腿坐在上面，这样大家就知道去哪儿找我了。噢，天哪。如果他失踪了。我们就知道他在哪儿了。好吧。往桶里多投一点币。嘿，各位。
Today. Yes. Oh, we have a fellow we could really learn from. Okay. Now we're trying to entertain folks with talking. Sure. We are. Okay.
今天。是的。噢，我们有了一位我们可以真正向他学习的伙伴。好吧。现在我们要通过谈话来娱乐大众。当然。我们会的。好吧。
Well, this guy is a professional talker. He's a respected talker. He's an awarded talker. Seven Emmys. What? For talking. Wow. What?
好吧，这家伙是个专业的说话者。他是一位受人尊敬的说话者。他是一位获奖无数的说话者。七座艾美奖。什么？因为说话。哇。什么？
His subject. Get ready, Sean. Sports. And not just any sports. I'm all in. These are top sports. This man has been the play by play announcer for an astonishing six Super Bowls. Cliff Trisdale.
他的专长。准备好了，肖恩。体育。而且不仅仅是普通的体育。我全押了。这些都是顶级体育。这个人曾担任过惊人的六届超级碗的实况转播员。克利夫·特里斯代尔。
And 23 World Series. He's smart. He's handsome. He's a pilot, opera singer, and glass blower, but a professional husband, father, and friend. America, this is your own Joe Buck. No. Joe? Joe Buck.
还有23届世界大赛。他很聪明。他很帅。他是一名飞行员、歌剧演员和玻璃吹制工，同时也是一位杰出的丈夫、父亲和朋友。美国，这就是你们自己的乔·巴克。不。乔？乔·巴克。
I even know who Joe Buck is. Get in here. Joe Buck. Sean, I'm sorry. No, I'm sorry. Listen, Sean's got questions. I got questions for you. I know who you are.
我甚至知道乔·巴克是谁。进来吧。乔·巴克。肖恩，我很抱歉。不，我很抱歉。听着，肖恩有问题。我有问题要问你。我认识你。
Wow. He does. It's been my nightmare since I, you know, begged Justin to come on this and it's been my nightmare to be revealed. And then all of a sudden, everybody's like, wha, wha, wha. No. No, no, no. No, Joe.
哇。他真的认识。自我（你知道的）恳求贾斯汀来上这个节目以来，这一直是我的噩梦，我的真实身份被揭露一直是我的噩梦。然后突然之间，每个人都发出“哇，哇，哇”的声音。不。不，不，不。不，乔。
Here I am. Wow. I'm sorry. I have noticed from listening to the show a couple of times that I end up talking. Your own show, you mean? Our own show. I started out talking about our guest's appearance. And it's a little weird, but I can't help it because I'm looking at you.
我来了。哇。我很抱歉。通过听了几次节目，我注意到我最后总是忍不住说话。你自己的节目，你是这意思？我们自己的节目。我一开始在谈论我们嘉宾的外表。这有点奇怪，但我控制不住，因为我在看着你。
Look at the shoulders on you. Now we don't usually see those under the suit, but what do you build? Houses on the weekends? I do. Yes. Good for you. I lift very heavy things. You got a little workout routine there?
看看你的肩膀。平时在西装下面可看不到这些，你这是怎么练的？周末盖房子吗？我是。是的。真不赖。我举很重的物件。你有什么健身计划吗？
I do. Yeah. I'll throw some weight around. Did you blast back some buys today? I did not. I barely just crawled out of bed. I'm in Mexico. It is.
有的。是的。我会举些重物。你今天去狂练二头肌了吗？我没有。我刚从床上爬起来。我在墨西哥。确实。
We are recording this on a Saturday morning. Yeah. I realized that when I'm on with the likes of you, Saturday morning doesn't really feel any different than a Tuesday morning or a Wednesday morning. No, it's Saturday every day for us. So yeah, last night I went to a wedding. I'm in Mexico. So is that why you're in Mexico because of the wedding?
我们是在周六早上录制这期节目的。是的。我意识到，当我和你们这样的人在一起时，周六早晨感觉其实和周二早晨或周三早晨没什么两样。对，对我们来说每天都是周六。所以，是的，昨晚我去参加了一个婚礼。我在墨西哥。所以你因为婚礼才在墨西哥吗？
We're actually between homes in my hometown of St. Louis. So we're waiting for a new home to be ready and my wife of seven years and our three-year-old twin boys are now down here in Mexico with me for the better part of five weeks. Why? So we're just kind of hanging out down here. Wow. Okay. So you have a five-week wait on the new house.
我们其实是在我的家乡圣路易斯的两处住所之间过渡。所以我们在等待新家准备好，我结婚七年的妻子和我们三岁的双胞胎男孩现在和我一起在墨西哥待将近五个星期。为什么？所以我们只是在这里闲逛。哇。好吧。所以你在新房子那里要等五周。
Congratulations. Yeah. So you have, was it just coincidence that you knew somebody that was getting married down there? Or are you a bit of a crash-er? Total coincidence. Total crash-er. Yeah.
恭喜。是的。所以，你刚好认识一个在那里结婚的人，这只是巧合吗？还是你有点像个不请自来的闯入者？纯属巧合。纯属不请自来。是的。
So Sean Payton, the head coach of the New Orleans Saints, it's a name drop. An incredible running back, by the way. Yes. Different guy, but close and I know you're kidding and I found out I saw these people around the place where we have our house here and I said, well, what's everybody doing down here? Well, we're here for Sean Payton's wedding. So I text Sean Payton, I said, hey, what time's the wedding?
所以新奥尔良圣徒队的主教练肖恩·佩顿，这里顺便提个名。顺便说一句，他是一个出色的跑卫。是的。不是同一个人，但很接近，我知道你在开玩笑，我发现我在我们在这儿有房子的那个地方周围看到了这些人，我就说，大家在这儿都在干什么呢？噢，我们是来参加肖恩·佩顿的婚礼的。所以我给肖恩·佩顿发短信，我说，嘿，婚礼几点开始？
What do we wear? What, you know, what, what kind of attire is it beach casual? I'm sure. Ha, ha, ha. Just kidding. Have a great wedding. Good luck to you guys. And then it was, you got to come.
我们穿什么？什么，你知道的，穿什么服装，是海滩休闲风吗？我敢肯定。哈哈，开玩笑的。祝你们婚礼愉快。祝你们好运。然后就是，你得来。
And then it was, then I felt horrible because he's over the top. I mean, I feel so bad. I didn't know you were down here. So we ended up going last night. My wife and I, and we basically did crash Sean Payton's wedding. But let's be honest, Joe. Hi, Joe. Good to meet you.
然后我就觉得糟透了，因为他太客气了。我是说，我觉得太糟糕了。我不知道你在这儿。所以我们昨晚最终去了。我和我妻子，我们基本上就是不请自来地闯入了肖恩·佩顿的婚礼。但说实话，乔。嗨，乔。很高兴认识你。
And I'm a fan and I want to get into all that, but let's be honest about the original text. I hear you're getting married. And even though it's a joke, let's be really, let's get real for a second. You wanted the invite. I did. Yeah. Okay.
我是你的粉丝，我想深入了解所有这些，但关于最初的那条短信，咱们说实话。我听说你要结婚了。尽管是个玩笑，但让我们真的，认真讨论一秒钟。你是想要那份请柬的。我是想要。是的。好吧。
This is anathema to anything I would consider enjoyable. A wedding, isn't a wedding something that most red-blooded knuckle-dragging males want to try to avoid attending? That's true. But it's 52. It's been a long time. Sean's 57. This is like the next go-around.
这与我视为享受的任何事情都背道而驰。婚礼，婚礼难道不是大多数血气方刚、满脑粗俗的男性都想尽量避免参加的活动吗？确实如此。但已经52岁了。这已经是很久以前的事了。肖恩57岁了。这就像是下一轮的人生循环。
I've had my own second go-around. So this was kind of a different wedding. The actual ceremony lasted seven minutes. And then it was down onto the beach and everybody's having fun. Joe, you got to know that Jason, we've been through this before, Jason asked me not to invite him to my wedding and I didn't. And then 10, 12 years later, it's like, I can't believe you didn't invite me to your wedding.
我自己也经历过第二轮循环。所以这算是一场不太一样的婚礼。真正的仪式持续了七分钟。然后大家就到海滩上去了，每个人都很开心。乔，你得知道，杰森，我们以前经历过这个，杰森曾要求我不要邀请他参加我的婚礼，我照办了。然后10、12年后，他就变成了，我简直不敢相信你没邀请我参加你的婚礼。
I'm like, no, you asked me not to invite you. Yeah. It's like writing no gifts on an invite and you expect people to bring something. Wait, why, J, why do you not like weddings? Well, because they're just stiff, stodgy, scheduled, awkward, long. You know why? Because it's not about him. And I don't drink anymore.
我就说，不，是你要求我不要邀请你的。是的。这就像在请柬上写着“谢绝礼品”，却指望别人带点什么来。等等，为什么，杰，为什么你不喜欢婚礼？因为婚礼太死板、乏味、死气沉沉、尴尬、漫长。你知道为什么吗？因为那不是为了他。而且我不再喝酒了。
There it is. There it is. If I drink, boy, I'd be a pastor or a reverend or who's the person that does the officiating? Either one. Either one works. So what I'm saying is because we went to a wedding and because my wife and I do drink, this morning came early. So I had to clear the cobwebs.
原因在这。原因在这。如果我喝酒的话，天哪，我早就成了一个牧师、神父，或者那个主持婚礼的人是谁来着？哪个都行。哪个都行。所以我想说的是，因为我们去参加了一个婚礼，而且我和我妻子确实喝酒了，所以今天早上来得很早。所以我得清醒一下大脑。
I have to, right now, the three year old twins are bound and gagged in the back of our house so that they don't make noise on this podcast. Sure. Well, just don't worry. It came early as Jason's nickname. Now, listen, let me ask you a question because you've got the kids there and you went to the wedding and we know Jason hates a wedding. And it brings up a thing that I'm avoiding today myself.
我现在必须，三岁的双胞胎被五花大绑塞在我们房子的后面，这样他们就不会在这个播客里制造噪音了。当然。好吧，别担心。来得很早就像是杰森的绰号。现在，听着，我问你个问题，因为你有孩子在那儿，你也去了婚礼，我们知道杰森讨厌婚礼。这勾起了一件我今天也在刻意回避的事情。
There were three kids' birthday parties I could have gone to today that I was invited to, two of which are for one-year-olds. I have a longstanding rule. If you invite me to a one-year-old birthday party, it means you don't like me because I think, first of all, the fucking kid's not going to remember. And I don't want to, you know, sorry. The child... Well, I'm saying that to my wife all the time.
今天本来有三个孩子的生日派对我可以去，我也收到了邀请，其中有两个是一岁小孩的生日派对。我有一个长期遵循的原则。如果你邀请我去参加一岁小孩的生日派对，那就意味着你其实不喜欢我，因为我觉得，首先，这狗屁小屁孩根本记不住。而且我不想，你知道的，抱歉。这孩子……好吧，我一直在对我的妻子这么说。
This is her first go around with kids. I have 25 and 22-year-old daughters. So the idea of making it even a point to run back home if we're out of town or if we're working to go to the actual boy's birthday on the 26th of April, that doesn't really count until they're, until they can count. That doesn't count until they're at least six and they can go, oh, today's my birthday. They have no clue. They have no clue what's happening.
这是她头一次带孩子。我有25岁和22岁的女儿。所以，如果我们外出或者在工作，甚至还要专门赶回家去参加4月26日那个男孩的生日，这其实根本不算数，直到他们，直到他们会数数。这根本不算数，直到他们至少六岁，能够说，噢，今天是我的生日。他们完全一无所知。他们根本不知道发生了什么。
And I think that there are a lot of people are going to say, oh, what a grumpy, what a grumpy dude. But I really... Yes, I am. Same here. I believe that we should not have to go to children's birthday parties before they know... Realize what they are.
而且我觉得会有很多人说，噢，真是一个暴躁的、脾气古怪的家伙。但我真的……是的，我就是。我也是。我相信我们不应该在孩子们懂事之前……意识到这些是什么之前，去参加他们的儿童生日派对。
I completely agree. Even if they're on your own kids. I agree. This reminds me of something somewhat depressing you guys and listener, not super related. But did you know that, like, I'm 52, right? In January, I'm going to be 53. But that means that I have finished the 53rd year. Like I'm in the 53rd year right now.
我完全同意。哪怕是你自己的孩子也一样。我同意。这让我想起了一些对你们和听众来说有点令人沮丧的事情，虽然关系不大。但你知道吗，比如，我52岁了，对吧？在一月份，我要满53岁了。但这意味着我已经度过了第53个年头。就像我现在正处于第53个年头。
And in January, when you say, hey, happy birthday, you're 53, it means I just finished the 53rd year. That's a good point. Okay. Do you know that? Like when you turn one, you have lived one year. Will, don't look at me like you've never thought of this before. I've thought about it.
然后在 一月份，当别人说，嘿，生日快乐，你53岁了，这意味着我刚刚度过了第53个年头。这倒是个好观点。好吧。你知道这个吗？就像当你满一岁时，你已经生活了一年。威尔，别用那种好像你从来没想过这事的眼神看着我。我想过。
Because you haven't. Of course I have. Your brain doesn't work as fine as mine does. I think it's interesting. Of course I have. No. My mom, my mom, who is a lot. She goes, she'll say all the time, like, you're now in your 51st year.
因为你根本没想过。我当然想过。你的大脑运转得可没有我的那么精妙。我觉得这很有趣。我当然想过。不。我妈妈，我妈妈，她经常这样。她会一直说，比如，你现在正处于你的第51个年头。
And I'm like, yeah. So she's bright. Not you. Yeah. Well, yeah. So you're saying that just adds to your depression because you're actually one year older than you're saying. Actually a full year older.
而我会说，是的。所以她很聪明。你可不是。好吧，是的。所以你是说这只会增加你的沮丧感，因为你实际上比你说的要老一岁。实际上整整老了一岁。
Yeah. Joe, how young a guy are you? I am the same age as you. All right. I'm in my 53rd year. Okay. And so you've been at this a long time, a very long time. When you first thought about becoming a broadcaster, obviously it was at a time probably much younger
是的。乔，你有多年轻？我和你同龄。好吧。我正处于我的第53个年头。好吧，所以你干这行很久了，非常久。当你最初考虑成为一名广播员时，显然那时你可能比任何开始考虑职业生涯的人都要年轻得多。
than anybody starts thinking about a career because he's like third trimester. When I was in the third trimester, I was on my way out and I was like, I want to do what my dad does. You came out with a microphone in your hand. So for Sean and for Tracy, his dad, Jack, will broadcast her for over what, 60 years, I want to say? Yeah. I mean, yeah.
因为就像在妊娠晚期。当我在妊娠晚期时，我正准备出生，当时我就想，我想做我爸做的事。你出来时手里就拿着麦克风。所以对于肖恩和特雷西，他的父亲杰克来说，广播员生涯超过了，怎么说，60年？是的。我是说，是的。
Definitely over 50. He was with the Cardinals for 50 years. And how awesome that you followed in his footsteps and I think one could easily argue surpassed his accomplishments. Now, I say that too is grave once a year. We're very, very soon after the anniversary of his passing and that was back in 02. And I usually make a pilgrimage out there and go, hey, you'll kid one up. Look at me.
绝对超过50年。他在红雀队待了50年。你能追随他的脚步，这是多么了不起的事，而且我认为人们可以轻而易举地争辩说你超越了他的成就。现在，我也带着敬意这样说，就在他去世周年纪念日之后不久，那是在02年。我通常会去那里朝圣，然后说，嘿，老头子，把酒倒上。看着我。
Look at me. Is that something that you felt that you, did you feel like you didn't have any options because you just wanted to do what dad was or did you have passion for it at a young age? No, I had passion for it. I think the answer to that is no matter what your parent does, and I was really close. So I can joke about that stuff with my dad because I was one of the few people that could actually make him laugh.
看着我。这是不是让你觉得，你觉得自己别无选择，因为你只想做你父亲做过的事，还是你在很小的时候就对它充满热情？不，我对它充满热情。我认为这个问题的答案是，无论你的父母做什么，而且我和我爸非常亲近。所以我可以拿那些事跟我爸开玩笑，因为我是为数不多能真正把他逗笑的人之一。
So he took me on road trips when I was five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10 years old. I was in every National League city by the time I was 12. I was like his little traveling partner and he and I were more best friends than we were the typical father and son. So to answer the question, I think when your parent does something that as a kid, if you're close to that parent, you see they love your natural inclination is to go, well, man, my dad can't wait to go to work every day. That's what I want to do because my, and then when it's something so fun, I mean, I
所以在五、六、七、八、九、十岁的时候，他会带我进行公路旅行。到12岁时，我去过国家联盟的每一个城市。我就像是他的小旅行伙伴，比起典型的父子，我和他更像是最好的朋友。所以回答这个问题，我觉得当你的父母做一件事情时，作为一个孩子，如果你和那个父母很亲近，你看到他们热爱它，你自然的倾向就会是，噢，天哪，我爸每天都迫不及待地要去上班。这就是我想做的事，因为我的，而且当这是一件如此有趣的事情时，我是说，
spent every summer down at Bush Stadium and being on the, you know, inside of the ropes and playing catch in the outfield and shagging fly balls during batting practice and bat boing and doing all that other stuff. And then sitting in the booth all night and basically going through a master's class every night of the summer, listening to the actual radio broadcast and a headphone, watching my dad do it, watching the game myself. It just was, I was immersed in it to the point where, yeah, I just didn't want to be anything else.
我整个夏天都在布什体育场度过，在围绳内部，在 outfield（外场）接球，在打击练习时捡飞球，当球童，做所有这些其他事情。然后整晚坐在转播室里，基本上在夏天的每个晚上都经历一门硕士课程，戴着耳机收听实际的无线电广播，看我爸工作，自己看着比赛。我完全沉浸其中，以至于，是的，我不想做别的任何事。
I just wanted to be him. I get that. And what about meeting some of these, these early heroes of yours, these athletes? Was it, what about the saying, never meet your heroes? Did something go south at any point or was it all great? There were many times when I was nine, 10, 11 years old and we would walk by the hotel bar and I would see a player with somebody that didn't look a lot like his wife, curled up around a drink and I'd be like, dad, just put your head down, kid and keep walking.
我只想成为他。我理解这一点。那么遇到这些你早期的英雄，这些运动员，感觉如何？那句“永远不要去见你的偶像”这句话怎么样？有没有哪个时刻事情变得糟糕了，还是说一切都棒极了？在我九岁、十岁、十一岁的时候，有很多次我们路过酒店酒吧，我会看到一个球员和一个长得不太像他妻子的人依偎在一起喝着酒，我会说，爸爸，把头低下来，孩子，继续走。
That's what he would say. And that was a pretty good Jack Buck. Yeah. Yeah. Well, that came, you know, that's when kids would ask him, you know, how do you, how do you get into broadcasting, Mr. Buck? I want to, I want to be a broadcaster. I love the cardinals.
他会这么说。那真是一个非常典型的杰克·巴克。是的。是的，这来自于，你知道的，当孩子们问他，巴克先生，你是怎么进入广播行业的？我想成为一名广播员。我热爱红雀队。
I love what you do. Start smoking. That was his advice, which I, I don't, I don't condone. Did you smoke a bit growing up? I never smoked. I was the squarist, dorkiest kid and I think the reason why is I didn't want to, there were so, my dad's time at home was so fleeting during the high points of the summer and the fall when he was doing NFL games, I didn't want to waste that time being in trouble.
我热爱你做的事。开始抽烟吧。那是他的建议，不过我，我并不，我不赞同。你成长过程中抽过烟吗？我从不抽烟。我是最古板、最死板的孩子，我想原因在于我不想，我爸在夏天和秋天 NFL 赛季的高峰期里，在家里陪伴的时间是那么短暂，我不想把时间浪费在惹麻烦上。
So not that, you know, I, I didn't want to, oh, mom found Joey with a pack of Marlboro lights and now I'm grounded. I didn't want to waste any time that I could have with him out of the house when he was home. So I just didn't do, I didn't really get in trouble as a kid. So him being out of the house so much, I would imagine just about every weekend for six months. Do you feel, and I'm projecting here, cause like my, my mom was a stewardess for Pan Am for 30 years.
所以倒不是说，你知道的，我不想让妈妈发现乔伊藏了一包万宝路红，然后我被禁足。我不想浪费任何当他在家时我能和他在一起的时间。所以我只是不，我小时候真的不怎么惹麻烦。所以他经常不在家，我想象大概六个月里每个周末都是如此。你觉得，我在这里投射我自己的经历，因为就像我妈妈曾是泛美航空的空姐30年一样。
So her being. Flight attendant. Flight attendant nowadays. Yes. So, so two weeks of every month, basically she was out. And so now with all of the traveling I do, I basically work in Atlanta during the week and I'm home on the weekends. Joe used to see your mom, sometimes in the, in the player bar, man, did she love Pedro
所以她经常不在家。航班乘务员，现在叫空乘。是的。所以，基本上每个月有两个星期她都不在家。所以现在我所有的旅行，我基本上工作日在亚特兰大，周末在家。乔以前有时会在球员酒吧看到你妈妈，天哪，她是有多爱佩德罗·格雷罗？
Guerrero? Man. In fact, I see a little bit of Pedro in you. And now a word from our sponsor and now back to the show. So it helps with my guilt cause I feel like it's just sort of normal for a parent to be gone all the time. Do you feel the same way? Cause you got kids and you're gone all the time.
天哪。事实上，我在你身上看到了一点佩德罗的影子。现在插播一条赞助商广告，随后节目继续。所以这有助于缓解我的内疚感，因为我觉得父母经常不在家其实挺正常的。你也有同感吗？因为你也有孩子，而且你总是到处飞。
How do you do it? The best thing I can say to that, and we talk about this on our own podcast, which, which you were nice enough to be on. Let's tell Tracy what that's called. Daddy issues. Called daddy issues. And you can find that where you find your favorite podcast. Sure.
你是怎么平衡的？我能对此外界说的最好的一句话，就是我们在我们自己的播客里谈论过这个，而你也很友善地参与了。咱们告诉特雷西那个播客叫什么。老爹问题。叫做《老爹问题》。你可以在你喜欢播客的地方找到它。当然。
Is that right? And your co-host. My co-host is Oliver Hudson. Beautiful man. He's the, who has the, uh, the lot in life of being Kate Hudson's brother and Goldie Han son and Kurt Russell's stepson. And you talk about daddy issues. He has mommy issues.
是这样吗？还有你的联合主持人。我的联合主持人是奥利弗·哈德森。一个美丽的男人。他是那种，呃，拥有成为凯特·哈德森的兄弟、歌蒂·韩的儿子以及库尔特·拉塞尔的继子这样人生的人。你还在说老爹问题。他有一堆老爹问题。
He has sister issues. He has everything. Left-handed golf game up there with Phil Nicholson. Yeah. No, he does. And, uh, you know, as, as I tell him, because he's, he's just obsessed, his dad left him before he was 10 and, and he was just bound and determined to never be that dad. And so he's gone the entire opposite way and he won't accept work sometimes if it's
他有妈妈问题。他有一切问题。左手高尔夫球技跟菲尔·米克尔森不相上下。是的。不，他确实有，而且，你知道的，正如我告诉他的，因为他，他简直有心结，他的父亲在他10岁之前就离开了他，而他下定决心绝不成为那样一个父亲。所以他走了完全相反的路线，有时甚至不接受工作，如果这会
going to take him away from his kids. My dad, as I said, was my best friend. I took, I took advantage of all the, uh, opportunities his job gave myself and my sister when we were little. And then when he was in town or if, if it had been a long time, he'd take me on the road. If, if he and I could become best friends and, and I worship the ground he walked on, it can be done.
把他从孩子身边带走的话。我爸，正如我所说，是我最好的朋友。当我和我姐姐还小的时候，我充分利用了他这份工作给我和姐姐带来的所有机会。然后当他在镇上时，或者如果已经过了很久，他会带我上路。如果我和他能成为最好的朋友，而且我崇拜他走过的每一寸土地，这是完全可以做到的。
It's what you do with your time when you're home. So what you're implying is you're going to take twin boys on the road with you as soon as they're old enough to travel. No, I'm too old. I'm too old for that. I'm too old really to be their parent. And I, I have a really, uh, long standing now, three year, uh, argument with my wife where she is so tired of hearing me say, I'm 52, I've done this before.
关键在于你在家时如何利用你的时间。所以你的意思是，一旦双胞胎男孩大到可以旅行了，你也要带他们上路？不，我太老了。我太老了，干不了那个。我当他们的父母真的太老了。而且，我和我妻子有一个，呃，持续了三年的长期争辩，她已经厌倦了听我说，我都52岁了，我以前干过这行。
Can I get a fucking break here? Can I, can I just lay down? I just did. I'm with you. I'm one year old. I'm with you on that job. Oh my God. But my wife's so sick and Mike, he's saying my wife, Michelle, who's, who's an avid listener.
我能喘口气吗？我能躺一会儿吗？我刚做完。我和你一样。我才一岁。乔，在这点上我和你同感。噢，天哪。但我妻子听烦了，我说的是我的妻子米歇尔，她是个忠实听众。
And as I told, uh, Jason, when he was on our podcast, she has, uh, you know, one of those new fangled electric cars and, and on the screen, which is the size of, of a flat screen in a bar, when you get into the car, it used to have my podcast on it, like, oh, she left off at the 43 minute mark. And now it's just smart less, smart less, smart less. And she, I don't listen, he's a, Jason's a big fan of the smart list too. Yeah. I heard that at the top.
正如我告诉贾斯汀的，当他上我们的播客时，她有，你知道的，那种新型的电动汽车，而在那个像酒吧里的平板电视一样大的屏幕上，当你上车时，以前上面会播放我的播客，比如，噢，她停在第43分钟。而现在全都是《聪明糊涂虫》，《聪明糊涂虫》，《聪明糊涂虫》。而且她，我没听，杰森也是《聪明糊涂虫》的超级粉丝。是的。我在开头就听说了。
You know, I, I remember, I worked with Beau Bridges years ago and he would talk about when he did that, he did that show with his dad, Lloyd and his brother, Jeff, uh, they, they did that show, um, SeaQuest, do you remember that? Seawolf. Not Seawolf. Not airwolf. You're thinking. Airwolf.
你知道的，我记得，我多年前曾和博·布里奇斯合作过，他谈到过他当年和他爸爸劳埃德以及他弟弟杰夫一起拍的那部秀，他们拍的那部秀，呃，《深海寻宝》（SeaQuest），你还记得吗？《海狼》（Seawolf）。不是《海狼》。不是《飞狼》（Airwolf）。你想的是。飞狼。
The palace vertice. The one that was shot, they were in the ocean all the time and they were, and he said that he was like, we got to go to work with our dad every day. It was the greatest. And that really, you know, no, of course I don't, my kids don't come to work with me every day. You're not going to take your kids to work with you. No, but I'm kind of stuck in the middle too, where like I do, Joe's not going to do it
帕利斯维蒂斯。那部在海里拍的剧，他们一直在海洋里，他说，我们每天都能和爸爸一起去上班。那是棒极了。这真的，不，当然我不会，我的孩子们不会每天都来跟我上班。你不会带你的孩子去上班的吧？不，但我也处在中间的尴尬境地，就像我，乔也不会那样做。
either. No, I'll be, I'll be retired by the time they're going to get anything out of it. I will have ridden off into the sunset. No. Are you going to retire? No. Come on. You're just getting started.
不，等他们能从中得到什么的时候，我早就退休了。我早就骑着马驶向夕阳了。不。你要退休吗？不。少来。你才刚刚开始。
I don't know. How old was your dad when he stopped? He stopped like the minute he died. Yeah. Which was what? How old was he? Well, that'll put an end to it for sure. It slows you down.
我不知道。你爸退休时多大？他基本上到死的那一分钟才停下来。是的。那是几岁？他多大？好吧，那肯定会画上句号。这会让你慢下来。
It slows you down. How old was he? Was he 80? He was 78. 78. Okay. He left a bank with the DMC, went to the hospital in St. Louis for lung cancer surgery and basically never got out.
这会让你慢下来。他当时多大？他80岁了吗？他78岁。78岁。好吧。他从戴姆勒克莱斯勒的银行出来，去了圣路易斯的一家医院做肺癌手术，基本上就再也没出来过。
So he worked the last day he was outside of a hospital. Oh man. He did a fundraiser and then went into the hospital and seven months later he, he died. So you've got 25 years left and you don't even smoke. So that's, that's at a minimum. Yeah. Great. It's not happening.
所以他在离开医院前的最后一天还在工作。天哪。他参加了一个筹款活动，然后进了医院，七个月后，他就去世了。所以你还有25年，而且你甚至不抽烟。所以这，这只是最低年限。太棒了。不会发生的。
We're excited. I'm not growing old in the booth. In fact, and nobody cares. I mean, that was my dad's joke forever was, you know, I'm going to die in the booth someday and there are going to be two guys walking in the, down the street in St. Louis and one guy's going to turn to the next and say, Hey, did you listen to the game last night? Jack buck died in the fourth inning and the other guy will say, Oh, did the Cardinals win?
我们很激动。我可不会在转播室里变老。事实上，也没人在乎。我是说，那是我爸永远的笑话，你知道的，我总有一天会死在转播室里，到时候会有两个人在圣路易斯的街头走着，其中一个人会转向另一个人说，嘿，你听昨晚的比赛了吗？杰克·巴克在第四局去世了。而另一个人会说，噢，红雀队赢了吗？
Yeah. Nobody cares. I know what you're implying here and this is going to sound like smoke, but I, I disagree with you. I really care who's announcing my sports and specifically I love what you do because I don't know whether it's an acting talent or whether it's genuine, but you seem so relaxed and so casual and you so easily relay the play by play information that I need to enjoy the game and you make you, you actually alleviate stress for me because watching sports and
是的。根本没人会在乎。我知道你的弦外之音，这听起来可能像是在奉承，但我不同意你的看法。我真的很在乎是谁在转播我的体育比赛，尤其是，我非常喜欢你的工作，因为我不知道这是一种表演天赋还是出于真心，但你看起来是如此放松和随意，并且你能如此轻松地传达我享受比赛所需的实况转播信息，你让我感到放松，因为观看体育比赛和
caring about sports can be stressful, whether you're winning or losing. No, I agree. The fact that you're kind of have a steady hand at 10 and two and you're taking us through the game. I, not a lot of people do it like you. Well, thank you. And when I said, I agree, I agree that it can be stressful watching and I'm a huge St. Louis Blues fan.
关心体育比赛可能会充满压力，无论你是赢是输。不，我同意。事实是你能在10点和2点的位置保持稳定，带我们看完整场比赛。我，没多少人能像你这样做。谢谢。当我刚才说“我同意”时，我是同意观看比赛确实会产生压力，而且我是一个超级圣路易斯布鲁斯队球迷。
I'm a hockey fan and go ahead. Yeah. Well, this is my question for you. I'm sorry. You keep going and then I'm going to follow up. Yeah. He's the guest. Shut your mouth.
我是个冰球迷，你继续。好吧，这就是我要问你的问题。抱歉。你继续说，然后我再接着问。对，他是嘉宾。闭上你的嘴。
God. Your question took 20 fucking minutes. Go ahead. It's well articulate. Go, Joe. No, it's not. Go, Joe. Pick it up.
天哪。你这个问题花了整整20分钟。继续吧。表述得很清晰。来吧，乔。不，并不清晰。来吧，乔。接着说。
Cut him off. You explain your own question. Sorry, Joe. No, it's okay. Well, so I, you're right. It is stressful and I try to just get out of the way and sometimes that pisses people off. Sometimes, oh, he, you know, he thinks he's too cool.
打断他。你自己来解释你的问题吧。抱歉，乔。不，没关系。好吧，所以，你说得对，这确实有压力，我尽量置身事外，有时候这会惹恼别人。有时候，噢，他，你知道的，他觉得自己太酷了。
He doesn't care. He's not excited. It's actually the opposite. I, I, I try to highlight the game so much and it's TV. It's different. If you're doing the radio, it's, you have to say everything. You have to give all the detail TV is, it's almost redundant to be the play by play guy on TV.
他不在乎。他一点也不兴奋。其实恰恰相反。我，我，我极力想要突出比赛本身，而且这是电视转播。这不一样。如果你是在做电台转播，那就完全不同了，你必须说出所有事情。你必须给出所有的细节。而电视转播，身为电视实况转播员甚至有点多余。
You see a ground ball to the shortstop. You don't need me doing the TV to go ground ball to the shortstop. You just, you can kind of hit different notes in it and just get out of the way. And when a home crowd is going crazy, I love just kind of saying, oh, I love just kind of saying, home run, you know, Dodgers are up five to two engine. That sounds good. Our director goes, you know, that's when he goes to work. His name's Matt Gangle and he's showing, you know, you and the highly expensive seats
你看到游击手接到了一个地滚球。你不需要我在电视上说“游击手接到了地滚球”。你只需要在其中融入不同的音调，然后退居幕后就行了。当主场观众疯狂时，我喜欢那种轻描淡写地说一句，噢，我喜欢那种轻描淡写地说一句，本垒打，你知道的，道奇队5比2领先，干得漂亮。听起来不错。我们的导播就会说，你知道的，这就是他开始工作的时候。他叫马特·甘格尔，他在镜头里展示，你知道的，你和那些坐在前排昂贵座位上的观众，
down front and he's showing Bert Sugarman and he's showing Mary Hart and he's showing all of these people. Me and Hartwell, just, just, just, you and Hartwell, right. Thinking about what club opening you're going to later that night. Matt Gangle, first of all, I want to say, I want to give a shout out to Matt because I want Matt to highlight me next time I'm at an event. It's done. Let me, I mean, he sounds like a great guy and a very cool guy.
他在展示伯特·萨戈曼，在展示玛丽·哈特，在展示所有这些人。我和哈特韦尔，就，就，就，你和哈特韦尔，对吧，在想着待会儿要去哪个夜店的开业派对。马特·甘格尔，首先，我想说，我想向马特大声喊话，因为下次我参加活动时，我希望马特能特写我。没问题。我是说，听起来他是个好人，也是个非常酷的家伙。
That sounds like a job for Lewis Kay, but we'll leave that for another day. Does that sound like a job for Lewis Kay? Get the shout out. Is this Lewis's first nod on the podcast? It is definitely. It shouldn't be. It shouldn't be. I mean, what kind of person are you?
这听起来像是刘易斯·凯的工作，但我们把这个留到以后再说吧。这听起来像刘易斯·凯的工作吗？大声喊话。这是刘易斯在这档播客中第一次被提及吗？绝对是。这不应该。这不应该。我是说，你到底是什么样的人？
So listen, so Joe, so I was going to, you mentioned the St. Louis Blues. There are a couple of things I want to talk about. Sean's interest was peaked when we talked about all this dad stuff and he really, and I want to get into that because it's no, no, I do because this is something that's very interesting. We've talked a lot about on the podcast recently and I know that it's something that you, you know, that is a conversation that's sort of a non-going conversation that we've been having for a while.
所以听着，乔，我本来想，你提到了圣路易斯布鲁斯队。还有几件事我想聊聊。肖恩一听到我们聊这些老爸的事情，兴趣就被勾起来了，他真的，我想深入聊聊这个，因为不，不，我真的想，因为这是一件非常有趣的事情。我们最近在播客里讨论了很多次，我知道这是你，你知道的，这是一个我们一直在进行的持续性对话。
But you mentioned hockey. What are the, what are the sports because you call primarily baseball and football. You're on the, you're on the baseball over there on the Fox and then you're on the football with T. Aikman. Yes. What's Troy, do you watch went Troy Aikman? Sorry. Thank you, Sean.
但你提到了冰球。还有哪些运动——因为你主要解说棒球和橄榄球。你在福克斯负责棒球，然后和特·艾克曼一起负责橄榄球。是的。特洛伊，你看过特洛伊·艾克曼的比赛吗？抱歉。谢谢你，肖恩。
What sports do you enjoy? If you're going to turn the TV on, what sport will you turn the TV on to watch? For instance, Al Michaels sits behind Lewis Kay at the Kings games. That's where his tickets are. And I see, sometimes I go with Lewis and I sit there and I talk to Alice's great guy. He loves hockey. Do you believe in miracles at the end of every game? And as a Canadian, I think like, yeah, but none of our NHL players were playing.
你喜欢哪些体育运动？如果你打开电视，你会转到什么体育频道去观看比赛？比如说，阿尔·迈克尔斯就坐在国王队比赛中刘易斯·凯的身后。那是他的票所在的位置。我看到，有时我会和刘易斯一起去，坐在那里和阿尔聊天，阿尔真是个大好人。他热爱冰球。你相信每场比赛结束时的奇迹吗？作为一个加拿大人，我觉得，当然，但当时我们的 NHL 球员根本没有上场。
Can you imagine if who would have been playing for team Canada in 1980? You would have had Mike Bossy. You would have had Wayne Gretzky. You would have had, anyway, it doesn't matter. Just get over it. Just get over it. Let us have a moment. You guys can have that moment.
你能想象如果1980年加拿大队是由谁来出战会怎样吗？你会有迈克·博西。你会有韦恩·格雷茨基。你会有，不管怎样，这不重要。别纠结了。别纠结了。让我们享受一会儿。你们可以享受那一会儿。
Can we just have our moment? You know, you've been hogging that moment forever, but what sport will you turn the TV on to watch? What do you love to watch other than baseball and football, hockey or golf? And I never understood golf as a kid. I love to play golf, um, but I never understood it on TV. I got to call five us opens, which was a thrill. Wait, really?
我们就不能享受一下属于我们的时刻吗？你知道的，你们一直在独占那个时刻，不过你会打开电视看什么体育比赛？除了棒球和橄榄球，你还喜欢看什么？冰球还是高尔夫？我小时候从来没搞懂过高尔夫。我喜欢打高尔夫，呃，但我从没看懂过电视上的高尔夫。我曾解说过去五届美国公开赛，那真是令人激动。等等，真的吗？
Uh, tell me something, Joe, it's psychologically. What is the show? Welcome. Yeah. What is the thrill of watching golf on TV? Well, it's a chance to just go to sleep. That was going to be my point. That's how it's going to say.
乔，告诉我一件事，从心理学上讲，这是个什么节目？欢迎。是的。看电视高尔夫的刺激之处在哪？噢，这就是一个睡觉的好机会。我本来正想这么说呢。我刚才也想这么说。
As, as the aforementioned in my 53rd year father of three year old twin boys, if there's any moment to just kind of power down and go see three PO just freezing out and that's golf. Yeah. Right. Right. Okay. And then they jump on you and then they jump on me.
作为刚才提到的正处于第53个年头、育有三岁双胞胎男孩的父亲，如果有什么时刻可以让你彻底关机，像C-3PO一样直接死机，那就是高尔夫。是的。对。对。好吧。然后他们就会扑向你，然后他们扑向我。
And they, you know, one of my kids at his birthday party, I'm not going to name him. It could be one of two. It could be Blake or Wyatt bit me in the crotch area when he was, that's what made me think of it when you said hit me. I've actually been bitten in my very, very private area with his head, but he was scared of a life size real moving Batman that was his uncle coming to his birthday party. I was holding a cup of coffee. He buries crying and buried his head in my crotch and then, and then, and then went one
然后，你知道的，我的一个孩子在他的生日派对上——我不打算说出他的名字。可能是布莱克或怀亚特中的一个——在我裆部咬了一口，当我听到你说打我的时候，我突然想到了这个。我其实在非常非常私密的部位被他的头撞过，但他当时是被一个真人大小、会动、是他叔叔扮演的蝙蝠侠吓坏了，当时那个蝙蝠侠来参加他的生日派对。我当时正端着一杯咖啡。他放声大哭，把头埋在我的裆部，然后，然后，然后又来了一次。
more. Hang on a second. Hang on a second. Hang on a second. So this birthday party is in the morning because you're having a coffee. It was midday. And then Michelle's brother shows up and says, Hey, I got this new suit. I'm working kids parties.
等一下。等一下。等一下。所以这个生日派对是在早上，因为你在喝咖啡。那是中午。然后米歇尔的兄弟出现了，说，嘿，我弄了套新衣服。我在儿童派对上兼职。
Right. Can I get a couple bucks? I bought the suit. You bought the suit. So it's Michelle's brother. This is Michelle's brother. This is my wife's brother. Yeah.
对。能给点小钱吗？我买了这套衣服。你买了这套衣服。所以这是米歇尔的兄弟。这是米歇尔的兄弟。这是我妻子的兄弟。是的。
I made my brother-in-law get into the suit that I got on Amazon. It was a great suit. I just didn't want to do it. And I just said, Hey, why don't you run around from the side of the house and the next thing you know, I have an open wound on the head of my friend. So Joe, listen, I want to go back to, to the art of what you do because I think it is kind of amazing. Anybody who does what you do to say that hyper focused every single game and you have to
我让我的小舅子穿上了我在亚马逊上买的那套衣服。那是一套很棒的衣服。我只是不想自己穿。我当时就说，嘿，你为什么不从房子侧面跑出来，结果紧接着，我朋友的头上就多了一道开放性伤口。所以乔，听着，我想回到，探讨你所做事情的艺术性，因为我觉得这真的很了不起。任何做你这种工作的人，都能在每一场比赛中保持高度专注，并且你必须……
know like the stats and the players and the plays and it doesn't get exhausting after a while to, to be that laser focused on every single aspect of every game, every day. There have been X players right off the field. Ronnie Lott is a guy that, that stands out to me that, that had safety for the San Francisco 49ers. Only has nine fingers. Yes. Yes.
知道吧，比如统计数据、球员和比赛，每天对每场比赛的每一个细节都保持那种高度专注，时间久了难道不会觉得筋疲力尽吗？有些球员一离场就……罗尼·洛特（Ronnie Lott）让我印象深刻，他曾是旧金山49人队的突前安全卫。只有九根手指。没错。没错。
Well, nine and a half. Tell Sean that story. That'll impress him. He lost the tip of his finger and didn't lose it voluntarily said, let's take it off. Right. Yeah. And it did. Yeah.
好吧，九个半。把这个故事讲给肖恩听。那会让他印象深刻。他丢了指尖，而且不是自愿失去的，不是说“咱们把它切掉吧”。没错。是的。而且确实切了。是的。
Why? Correct me if I'm wrong. He got his pinky smash between two helmets. The doctor said, we cannot save your finger. You can't play football anymore or you can have it chopped off. He said, go ahead and chop it off. I got to, I got to keep playing. I think it was just the tip.
为什么？如果我错了请纠正我。他的小指被卡在两个头盔之间。医生说，你的手指保不住了，你不能再踢足球了，或者你可以把它切掉。他说，那就切掉吧。我得、我得继续踢球。我想那只是指尖。
Hang on, man. Let's keep it going. When you say just the tip, this is, this is a real thing. This is a family podcast. So, you know, we got people like Michelle listening here. I pointed out my mom is listening. Jesus Christ. I'm sorry.
等等，伙计。咱们继续。当你说“只是指尖”的时候，这、这可是个真事。这是一个适合全家收听的播客。所以，你知道的，我们这里有像米歇尔这样的人在听。我指出来我妈也在听。天呐。对不起。
It's just the tip of the finger. Do I need to be more specific? Yes. Okay. So he got off the field, went in, into the booth and, and he said, that was harder for me than playing. I have never had to concentrate longer in my life for three hours and now more than ever with social media and oh my God, if you make a mistake and oh my God, if, if you just misspeak
这只是手指尖而已。我需要说得更具体点吗？是的。好吧。所以他一离开球场，走进解说间，然后他说，对我来说，这比比赛还要难。我这一生中从来没有连续专注过三个小时，而且现在比以往任何时候都更严重，因为社交媒体，天呐，如果你犯了一个错误，天呐，如果你、如果你不小心说错了话……
somehow and, and you know, you say something that you didn't mean, right? Oh my God. It's so fun. What a, what a time. Yeah. What an incredible time. People say, I think we don't have enough social media. We, we got to double it.
不知怎么的，然后，你知道的，你说了一些你本意并非如此的话，对吧？天呐。太有趣了。这算什么、什么时代啊。是的。多么不可思议的时代。人们说，我觉得我们的社交媒体还不够。我们、我们得加倍。
It's so great. And I want to hear from everybody. But isn't it kind of like a tree in the forest? So like, if you don't look at the comments, if you don't go on social media, does it really exist? If I did, I would quit. If I did and I, and I'm so fragile as I told you on our podcast, Jason, from being the fact getting, getting daddy issues, the getting picked on, yeah, let's get that right available
太棒了。而且我想听听所有人的意见。但这不就像森林里的一棵树吗？比如，如果你不看评论，如果你不上社交媒体，它真的存在吗？如果我看了，我就会辞职。如果我看了，而且正如我在我们的播客里告诉你的那样，杰森，我很脆弱，因为我有“恋父情结”……被挑剔、被找茬，是的，让我们把这个搞清楚
wherever you get your podcast as being picked on as a kid, when, when I read that stuff, I'm not saying people weren't picked on as kids. Most of us were for some reason, but it just goes right back into that. And I, and so I'm always trying to please, I'm always trying to go Joe, the picked on kids movement is fucking mad at you right now. Now they're mad at you. Hey, but why, why do I see on the wiki page here that you're famously criticized and tormented? I've never heard any of that.
无论你在哪里收听播客，小时候被人找茬，当我看到那些东西时，我并不是说别人小时候没被人找茬过。我们大多数人出于某种原因都经历过，但那直接勾起了那种感觉，所以，我总是试图取悦别人，我总是试图去……乔，“被找茬的孩子”运动现在他妈的生你的气了。现在他们生你的气了。嘿，但是为什么、为什么我在维基百科上看到你饱受著名批评和折磨？我从来没听说过这些。
I don't know what the hell they're, why, why is that? Because you're barely on, you just stick your toe into the social media. But is that a thing? Are you really, are you really criticized? Like you're at the top of your field. Who's, who's criticizing you? Because, you know, for you going to bed in your Dodger PJs every night, you all season long.
我不知道他们到底是怎么回事，为什么、为什么会这样？因为你几乎不上网，你只是把脚趾头伸进社交媒体里。但真有这回事吗？你真的、真的受到批评吗？就像你处于你这个领域的顶峰。谁、谁在批评你？因为，你知道的，你整个赛季每天晚上穿着道奇队的睡衣睡觉。
He's got him on right now. Oh yeah, I know. There's an LA somewhere on there. If you, all year long, you hear your TV announcers do the games basically as a Dodger fan. And that's how it's supposed to be. That's what I used to do as a Cardinal announcer. Joe Davis and Oral just bring it home to me every day. And if the Dodgers hit a home run, they're thrilled.
他现在就穿着呢。哦，对，我知道。上面某处有个“LA”标志。如果你，一整年，你听电视解说员解说比赛，基本上就像个道奇队球迷。这本来就该这样。这就是我以前当红雀队解说员时的做法。乔·戴维斯和奥拉尔每天都把胜利带给我。如果道奇队打出全垒打，他们会欣喜若狂。
If the Dodgers give up a home run and now the Dodgers are losing, the call goes down. I have to get excited for both teams because I'm not there representing either team. I'm there representing, you know, Switzerland. So I don't care who wins, but when fans hear the announcer on TV, get excited for the other team hitting a home run, they get pissed off. And I get it. So you're saying you get excited when a Cardinal hits a home run, even though it's a national broadcast?
如果道奇队失掉全垒打，现在道奇队落后了，声音就会低落下来。我必须为两支球队感到兴奋，因为我不是去代表某一支球队的。我是去代表，你知道的，瑞士的。所以我不在乎谁赢，但当球迷听到电视上的解说员为对方球队打出全垒打而感到兴奋时，他们会很生气。我懂。所以你是说当红雀队打出全垒打时你会感到兴奋，尽管这是一场全国直播？
No. That's not at all what I'm saying. I don't see how you can even derive that from what it is. Here comes the quote. That's the direct quote. Yes. And thanks a lot. Yeah.
不。我根本不是这个意思。我真不知道你怎么能从那些话里得出这种结论。名言来了。那是原话。是的。非常感谢。是的。
We thank you, Joe. We got the quote we wanted and we've got the controversy we wanted to start. Gotcha. Do you have Lewis on speed dial? I'd like to talk to Lewis. Right. I'd like to phone a friend. So Joe, let me ask you one question.
我们谢谢你，乔。我们得到了我们想要的引言，也得到了我们想要挑起的争议。明白了。你有路易斯的快捷拨号吗？我想跟路易斯谈谈。对。我想打电话给朋友。所以乔，让我问你一个问题。
So going back. So your dad, you loved what your dad did. You wanted to emulate your dad and you wanted to spend time with your dad, which makes total sense, but who other than your dad, did you look up to or do you currently look up to as in terms of broadcasters in sports or broadcasters in general or people that you have idols in that world? If Al Michaels is doing it, I want to listen to it and it's just very pleasing to my ear. Vince Scully is the greatest baseball broadcaster of all time.
那么回到正题。所以你的父亲，你热爱你父亲所做的事。你想效仿你的父亲，你想花时间陪你的父亲，这完全说得通，但是除了你父亲之外，在体育解说员或一般解说员方面，或者在你心目中的那些偶像人物中，你曾经崇拜过谁，或者目前崇拜谁？如果阿尔·迈克尔斯在解说，我想听，这非常悦耳。文斯·斯库利是史上最伟大的棒球解说员。
The mind blowing thing to me is that he worked by himself, uh, even to the bitter end, uh, when he was doing the games and that's just, that's a lot. What about Pat Samaral and John Madden? Oh my, so good. And we, and Troy and Chris Collinsworth, and I took their place at Fox and that, that was, you know, it was hard to kind of step in and my dad was my broadcast partner for over 10 years. And I, you know, I didn't know what to call him on the air was a dad was a jack was it
最让我感到不可思议的是，他一个人工作，呃，甚至到了最后关头，呃，当他解说比赛的时候，那真的是太不容易了。帕特·萨默拉尔和约翰·马登怎么样？哦天哪，太棒了。还有，特约和克里斯·柯林斯沃思，我接替了他们在福克斯的位置，那，你知道的，介入其中很难，而且我爸爸做了我十多年的解说搭档。然后，你知道的，我不知道在直播中该怎么称呼他，是叫“爸爸”还是“杰克”还是……
Hey, you, which is kind of what it became, I just didn't reference him by, right. That's how Jason references all the people that work on his crew, but go ahead. And so, uh, and so then we took over for Pat and John and, and I think they are to me. And again, I'm in my 53rd year. So that, that hits at my wheelhouse of what a big game in the NFL sounded like. It was Pat Samaral doing his Montana rice, right. Touchdown. And then John doing is he was the great straight man to John's kind of bam, boom, biff.
嘿，“你”，后来基本上就变成这样了，我只是不直接称呼他，对吧。杰森就是这样称呼他团队里所有人的，不过你继续。然后，呃，然后我们接替了帕特和约翰的位置，我认为他们对我来说——再次申明，我正处于职业生涯的第53个年头——所以这正中我下怀，让我回想起NFL一场大战听起来是什么样子的。那是帕特·萨默拉尔在解说蒙塔纳到莱斯的连线，对吧？“达阵！”然后约翰负责当约翰那种“砰、轰、啪”风格的绝佳捧哏。
You do any vocal, uh, uh, warmups, uh, preparation before you go, uh, any sort of ritual will it likes to gargle all kinds of things before he does his, his candy records and truck records. He must. I've never heard a more glorious voice than will, uh, you do anything other than just kind of show up and say, let's, let's, I think you say you have a war cry. Let's do this or let's get after it or something. Yeah, it's, it's definitely in the category of a war cry. Yeah.
你在上场前会做任何声乐、呃、热身、呃，准备工作吗？有什么仪式感之类的吗？威尔喜欢在做他的糖果唱片和卡车唱片之前漱口各种东西。他肯定会的。我从来没听过比威尔更嘹亮的声音了，呃，除了露面说一句“咱们、咱们”之外，你还会做别的吗？我想你说过你有一个战吼。我们开始吧，或者大干一场之类的。是的，这绝对属于战吼的范畴。是的。
I walk into the list. You do that. And then the guy follows me around. You need to catch phrase. We need, you need to write to really submit your place because you're there. You're going to be on the Mount Rushmore of American sports broadcasters, but we need to establish a kick-ass. Yeah.
我走进名单。你这么做了。然后那家伙跟着我到处转。你需要一个口号。我们需要，你需要写下来，以真正确立你的地位，因为你就在那里。你将登上美国体育解说员的拉什莫尔山，但我们需要树立一个强悍的形象。是的。
It was like, Hey, Joe Buck here for Fox Sports. Here we go. It's football time. You know what I mean? Like something like that. It's time for Fox football. You can incorporate a vinscully there. It's time.
就像是，嘿，我是福克斯体育的乔·巴克。我们开始吧。橄榄球时间到了。你知道我的意思吗？就像那样。福克斯橄榄球时间到了。你可以在那里融入一点文斯·斯库利的风格。时间到了。
Yeah. So when you, when you're listening to, to young announcers, what are some of the things that, you know, in your opinion, haven't, they haven't quite figured out yet. Like do you, don't be scared to not talk. Don't be scared of the silence. I, I think it's inherent within all of us, whatever we do, that if you're not talking or you're not reacting, it's in your mind, you're telling the audience, you don't know what to do.
所以当你在听年轻的解说员解说时，在你看来，有哪些事情是他们还没有完全搞懂的？比如，不要害怕不说话。不要害怕沉默。我认为这是我们所有人骨子里都固有的，无论我们做什么，如果你不说话或者没有反应，在你的潜意识里，你就是在告诉观众，你不知道该怎么办。
And, and I think a lot of times, especially when with technology and crowd mics being what they are and that ambient sound, you don't need to fill up every second with your voice. Let it read. I feel like he's talking to me. He's looking right at me. I think you're fucking, you're fucking talking. You just started immediately started talking.
而且我认为很多时候，特别是当科技和球场麦克风以及周围环境音达到某种程度时，你不需要用你的声音填满每一秒钟。让声音沉淀下来。我觉得他在跟我说话。他正看着我。我觉得你他妈的、你他妈的在说话。你刚一开口就开始说话了。
Was that out loud? Oh no, no, no, no. Case in point. Did I say that out loud? He started annoying you to become his friend because you're a baseball announcer. So how did he get your number? What was the thing? And how did he casually be like, Hey, we should text each other and start fucking bothering
刚才那是大声说出来的吗？哦不不不不不。这就是个例子。我刚才大声说出来了吗？他开始惹恼你，想跟你做朋友，因为你是个棒球解说员。那他是怎么拿到你的电话号码的？是怎么回事？他是怎么漫不经心地说，嘿，我们应该发短信互通有无，开始他妈的烦你的？
you? We had a media, we had a media. Let him talk. Let Joe talk. We had a mediator. His name's Heartwell. Yeah. Jason's buddy.
我们有个中间人，我们有个中间人。让他说。让乔说。我们有个中间人。他叫哈特韦尔。是的。杰森的朋友。
Heartwell. So I'd heard, I heard Jason. He won't remember this on stern talking about washing his hands in a bathroom and he was up in the press box area and he was in the media area washing. I went into, I went scrambling in there to pee. You know, that's the other part of broadcasting they don't tell you. If there's stage fright in your life, don't even apply because you have, you have a minute and a half to go to the bathroom and, and there's running involved.
哈特韦尔。所以，我听说，我听说杰森——他不会记得这事了——在霍华德·斯特恩的节目里谈到他在洗手间的洗手池洗手，他当时在记者席区域，正在媒体区洗手。我急急忙忙冲进去撒尿。你知道的，这是解说工作的另一个不为人知的方面。如果你的人生有舞台恐惧症，那就别来应聘，因为你只有一分半钟的时间去上厕所，而且这其中包含奔跑。
So you have to stay cardiovascularly in tune with yourself and never a diaper or a bottle under the counter. I have, I have peed in a bottle while calling an NFL touchdown. I swear to God. It was, yes. Good for you. I was peeing in a trash can and they came back. You don't have to brag.
所以你必须保持心血管机能处于良好状态，柜台下面可没有纸尿裤或者尿瓶。我真的、真的在解说NFL达阵得分时在瓶子里撒过尿。我发誓上帝。是的。真为你高兴。我当时正在垃圾桶里尿尿，他们就切回去了。你用不着吹牛。
Okay. Yeah. It's true. That's crazy. They handed me like a little water bottle. I'm like, I can't, the half wouldn't end. So that's not going to do it. Give me that.
好吧。是的。这是真的。太疯狂了。他们递给我一个小水瓶，我说，不行，半场比赛还没结束呢，这可不管用。把那个给我。
Yeah. And I was wearing a parka because it was freezing. It was in Milwaukee. While you're talking, you did that. While you're speaking, we came back from a break and I was peeing and the action started and I, I called a touchdown while urine was coming out of me. Can you say what the game was? What the touchdown was?
是的。而且我当时穿着派克大衣，因为冷得要命。是在密尔沃基。你边说话边做了那事。在你说话的时候，我们从广告休息切回来，我正在撒尿，比赛开始了，我一边尿尿一边解说了一个达阵。你能说出那是哪场比赛吗？哪个达阵吗？
You can go back and watch it. I'm pretty sure it was. I'm pretty sure it was Atlanta against green Bay and they played every year. Hard to believe now because of Lambo and the success of the Packers, but back then they played one home game at Milwaukee. I remember that county stadium. And so I, yeah, I, I, the bathroom was, was like over, it was like a mission impossible Tom Cruise thing to get to the bathroom in the stadium and the half wouldn't end.
你可以回去看录像。我很确信那是。我很确信那是亚特兰大对阵绿湾，他们每年都交手。现在因为兰博球场和包装工队的成功，这听起来有点让人难以置信，但当年他们每年在密尔沃基打一场主场比赛。我还记得那个县立体育场。所以，是的，我、我，那个洗手间简直像汤姆·克鲁斯的《碟中谍》一样，要穿过体育场去上个洗手间简直是不可能完成的任务，而且半场比赛就是不结束。
And I couldn't get there and I was just pounding water and it just, I was, I was crying. Water was trying to get out. And when you were announcing it, there was a little extra sound of relief in your voice when you were announcing it. Yeah. There was a little, that's six points. That's true though. And so yeah, that, that's another piece to the job.
我去不了，我一直在狂喝水，水简直要憋出来了。当我正在解说时，我的声音里带有一丝解脱的快感。是的。带有一丝，那是六分。不过这倒是不假。所以，是的，这也是这份工作的一部分。
They don't tell you in broadcast school or when you're a lucky nepotite. I just thought of it. I just thought of your, your, your catchphrase right at the start of the game, baseball or football. You go, here we go. The game of the week, the buck starts here. Oh, nice. Yes.
他们在广播学校里不会告诉你，或者当你是个幸运的裙带关系者时也不会告诉你。我刚想到的。我刚刚想到了你在比赛刚开始时的口号，无论是棒球还是橄榄球。你说，我们开始吧。本周焦点之战，巴克从这里开始。哦，不错。是的。
Well, that's free. Joe, go ahead. The buck starts here. You can have that. If you say it during a broadcast, I swear, I'm going to, you're going to make me so happy. You, I will make one person so happy. And the rest of them. And then that's one of those things.
好吧，那是免费的。乔，请说。巴克从这里开始。这个你可以拿去。如果你在解说中说出来，我发誓，你会让我超级开心。你，我会让一个人超级开心。其余的人。然后这就属于那种情况。
Like if we can just reach one person, we know we've done our job. That's true. We're going to be right back. All right. Back to the show. Joe, do you have like a, a something that you've, it doesn't have to be controversial or whatever, but anything that in the moment, you're like, it was so embarrassing and that you can't take it back.
就像如果我们能触动一个人，我们就知道我们尽了自己的职责。确实如此。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目中。乔，你有没有经历过那种，倒不一定非得充满争议什么的，但就是任何在那个当下的事情，你觉得太尴尬了，以至于无法收回。
And it's out there. Like you have a funny. There's a couple of things. The, the most notable is I mentioned we did the U S open and they're playing at Aaron Hills and Brooks Kepke is one of the great players in the game to this day. This was I think 2016. He wins the U S open, wins his first major. And I'm trying to pass myself off as a golf announcer and I'm doing my best.
而且事情已经发生了。比如你有什么趣事吗？有几件事。最著名的是我提到我们解说了美国公开赛，当时他们在艾伦希尔斯球场比赛，布鲁克斯·科普卡至今仍是这项运动中最伟大的球员之一。我想那是2016年。他赢得了美国公开赛，赢得了他的第一个大满贯。而我正试图伪装成一个高尔夫解说员，我已经尽力了。
We've had a pretty good week at Fox. I felt like I did a decent job that year. It was my second year doing it. And at the end, this guy, Katka wins the U S open and this girl keeps showing up in every shot, every shot, kissing him, holding up the trophy. We did it. We did it. I get a card handed to me from a guy in the back of the booth who'd been handing me
我们在福克斯度过了相当不错的一周，我觉得那年我做得还算不错。那是我做这行的第二年。最后，这家伙科普卡赢得了美国公开赛，而这个女孩不断出现在每一个镜头里，每一个镜头都在亲吻他、高举奖杯。“我们做到了！我们做到了！”解说间后面的人递给我一张卡片，他这一周里一直给我递卡片
cards all week that were dead on and made me sound a thousand times smarter than I actually am and a thousand times more clued in. And he's got all the stats of who the girl is. And so I just read the card. That's a so-and-so. She's a soccer player at Michigan state and I'm working with Brad facts. And then he goes, actually, Joe, the person you just said is his ex-girlfriend. This is his new girlfriend, Jenna Sims.
卡片上的信息精准无比，让我听起来比实际聪明了一千倍，也比实际了解情况得多。上面写着关于这个女孩身份的所有统计数据。于是我就照着卡片念了。那是某某某。她是密歇根州立大学的英式足球运动员，当时我正和布拉德·法克森合作。然后他说：“其实，乔，你刚才说的那个人是他的前女友。这是他的新女友珍娜·西姆斯。”
Oh wow. And I'm like, uh, okay, good night. Everybody. Good night. Everybody. Good night. Did Kepka want to come and tune you up? No.
哦，天哪。然后我就想，呃，好吧，大家晚安。大家晚安。晚安。科普卡想来找你算账吗？没有。
I, so I, then I get facts and has everybody's number. Of course. Fax and would know that. I mean, they had been dating for the, like a month or whatever it had been at that point, but facts and knows he's in everybody's business. He's in everybody's business. I love him, but I, I, I text him and I say, Hey, give me Kepka's number. And I texted Kepka right after he wins the U S open.
所以，然后我找了法克森，他有所有人的电话号码。当然。法克森肯定知道这一点。我的意思是，他们当时已经约会了一个月左右，或者差不多那个时间，但法克森什么八卦都知道。他什么八卦都知道。我爱死他了，但我、我发短信给他说：“嘿，把科普卡的号给我。”我在科普卡赢得美国公开赛后立刻给他发了短信。
I said, Hey, I don't know if you've heard this, but I kind of fucked up on national TV. I said your ex-girlfriend's name. I, I'm so sorry. I feel terrible. I shouldn't have ruined that moment for you. And he texted back like, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, crying emoji, all good, you know, great job or something like that.
我说：“嘿，我不知道你听说了没有，我在全国电视直播里搞砸了。我说了你前女友的名字。我真的很抱歉。我感觉糟透了。我不该毁了你那个时刻。”他回短信说：“哈哈哈哈哈哈，哭笑表情，没关系，你解说得很棒”或者类似的话。
And then he and I, and then you asked him if you could go to his wedding. Yeah. They are engaged. So I'm going to work so hard to get, to get invited to that wedding, whether I'm in that city or not. I, I will be there somehow, so I'd like to introduce them and fuck up her name for the second time in my life. That'd be so good.
然后他和我就，然后你问他你能不能去参加他的婚礼。是的。他们订婚了。所以我一定会拼尽全力去争取收到那场婚礼的邀请，不管我在那个城市还是不在。我无论如何都会出席的，我想向他们做个自我介绍，然后这辈子第二次把她的名字叫错。那可太棒了。
If you could tell that story and then once again to give, use the old girlfriend's name, bring it on. He's welcome. Mr. and Mrs. Joe, is there is what is, what, in your opinion, the best ballpark hot dog nationwide, please? I don't really dive into the hot dogs when I'm there. Look at that guy. He eats hot dogs.
如果你能讲完这个故事，然后再次用那个前女友的名字，尽管来吧。他很欢迎。乔先生和乔太太，在你看来，全国各地最好吃的球场热狗是什么，请告诉我？我到那儿去其实不怎么吃热狗。瞧瞧那家伙。他吃热狗。
Look at him. Look at him. You don't eat bad food. You don't eat the media food. He doesn't eat hot dogs. Look at him. He's in shape. By the way, I noticed you were in shape last year.
瞧瞧他。瞧瞧他。你不吃垃圾食品。你不吃媒体餐。他不吃热狗。瞧瞧他。他身材保持得很好。顺便说一句，我注意到你去年身材很好。
I really, you really start, whatever you were doing, I could, I was like, look at this son of a... Titer suits. No, he looks better. He just looks... It's waist up. I could see your jawline was popping last season. And I just thought this guy...
我真的，你真的开始，不管你当时在做什么，我都觉得：看看这个王八蛋……紧身西装。不，他看起来更好。他只是看起来……从腰部以上。上个赛季我能看出你的下巴线条很明显。我当时就想，这家伙……
And the hair looks frigging great, Joe. Let me tell you something. The hair looks great. I mean... That's the story, Sean, that I kind of will carry with me for the rest of my life, that I went in for my eighth hair transplant surgery back in the day. And I... You said it hurt your vocal cords, right?
而且头发看起来真他妈的棒，乔。我跟你说个事。头发看起来真棒。我是说……这就是那个故事，肖恩，我大概会带进棺材里，当年我去做第八次植发手术的时候。我……你说过这伤害了你的声带，对吧？
Well, for the first six, I was awake during this really painful procedure. Now this was back in the day. Right. So this is like 2011 when I got my last one, and the doctor... Well, they used to do it with a needle and thread, right? Needle and thread. And then all the hair from your armpits, the whole cast of people that were in there to donate hair to me, just different people.
嗯，前六次手术时，在这项极其痛苦的手术过程中我都是清醒的。那可是当年啊。没错。所以大约是在2011年我做最后一次的时候，医生……嗯，他们以前是用针线做的，对吧？针线。然后把你胳肢窝里所有的头发，还有里面所有捐头发的人，各种不同的人……
Wow. So... Wait, you've had eight? Okay, keep going. This is... And the doctor had said, you know, I know that, you know, you struggle during this procedure and you've had a lot of them. You know, you can go under and you can do a general anesthetic.
哇。所以……等等，你做过八次？好的，继续。这是……医生曾说过：“我知道，你知道的，你在手术过程中很痛苦，而且你做过很多次了。你知道的，你可以睡过去，做全身麻醉。”
Just the best. I was like, are you kidding me? He's like, yeah, but it's an extra $3,000. I'm like, I'll pay you 10. I don't want to be awake during this. I hate it and whatever. So they do the... You know, you sign out the waivers and all that, and they put a tube down my throat and
太棒了。我当时想：你在开玩笑吗？他说：对，但要多花3000美元。我说：我给你1万。我可不想在手术过程中醒着。我讨厌这个，随便怎样吧。于是他们做……你知道的，你签署了免责声明之类的东西，然后他们把一根管子插进我的喉咙里，
it sat on the nerve that fires my left vocal cord in a way that when I came out, I sounded like this and I had one vocal cord that was working and one that wasn't. Wow. And the story I told, we had McConaughey on our podcast recently, and I saw him in the shadow of where I'm sitting right now, back in 2011, and he's like, hey, Buckaroo, what's wrong with your voice? And I said... Buckaroo.
这根管子压迫到了控制我左侧声带的神经，导致我醒来时声音变成了这样，我只有一个声带能正常工作，另一个不行。哇。我讲过这个故事，我们最近请到了麦康纳来我们的播客，2011年我在我现在坐的这个地方的阴影里见过他，他说：“嘿，巴克小子，你的声音怎么了？”我说……巴克小子。
You said, what's wrong with yours? Did you light them up after that? And I told him the story and he just waited and he went, so what you're saying is... You fixed your video, you fucked up your audio. Oh, boy. I was like, yeah. And by the way, I just got on anti-depressants and I'm going through divorce. So I'm going to go over here and suck my thumb and cry to myself for a little while.
你说：“你的怎么了？”在那之后你把他们点着了吗？我把这个故事讲给他听，他等了一会儿，然后说：“所以你的意思是……你修好了你的视频，却把音频搞砸了。”哦，天哪。我当时想：是的。顺便说一句，我刚开始吃抗抑郁药，而且正在经历离婚。所以我要去那边吮吸我的大拇指，自怨自艾一会儿。
Joe, let me say this, and I don't use this term often, but you're a real hot mess. Keep going. Sorry. Go ahead. I'm good now. Back then, I was definitely hot. So eight treatments. Eight treatments on that.
乔，恕我直言，我不常使用这个词，但你真是一个一团糟的家伙。继续。抱歉。请继续。我现在好多了。当年我确实很火。所以做了八次治疗。做了八次治疗。我们完了吗？没有。
Eight treatments. Are we done? No. So I had one recently with the new methods, with a guy in LA whose client list, I found from another one of our guests, he's like, yeah, I had it done. It just came up organically and so then we became friends. Another Lewis K guy. You want to give the doctor a plug right here?
做了八次治疗。最近我又用新方法做了一次，是在洛杉矶找了一个医生，他的客户名单我是从我们的另一个嘉宾那里得知的，他说：“哦，我做过。”这事就自然而然地聊到了，然后我们就成了朋友。另一个路易斯·K（Louis K）的熟人。你想在这里顺便给这位医生打个广告吗？
No pun intended. Yeah. Well, he gave you one, so you know. So why do you have to have eight procedures? Can't you just have one good one? Massive head, Jason, and I have thin, wispy hair. Is it like one row at a time? Why can't they do the whole thing, especially if you're knocked out?
双关语就不必了。是的。好吧，他给了你一个，所以你知道的。那为什么你必须做八次手术呢？难道不能做一次效果好的吗？脑袋太大了，杰森，而且我的头发稀疏细软。是不是一次只能弄一排？为什么他们不能一次搞定整个头，特别是当你被麻醉的时候？
Yeah, you would think, and that's what led to my vocal cord paralysis, but it was six hour procedure, but back then it was not as great as it is now. How long before your voice came back? It was about seven, eight months somewhere. It must have been scary. I mean, that's your livelihood. How much hair do you now have in your throat? Well, I mean, every once in a while, one will get in there.
对啊，你会这么想，这也是导致我声带麻痹的原因，但那是一个六小时的手术，而且当年的技术可没有现在这么好。你的声音过了多久才恢复？大约七、八个月吧。当时一定很吓人。我的意思是，那是你的生计所在。你现在喉咙里有多少头发？嗯，我是说，偶尔会有一根钻进去。
Were you worried that your career was over with your voice being on the fence? Yeah, it was a mess, and I drove my daughter's crazy because I would drive into school in the morning and be like, how about this, does this sound better? Fly ball into right and back into grab it is Peterson, and that'll be two out. How's that? And I thought it was all over, but it just slowly came back. I could feel it getting better, but you couldn't hear it getting better, but it's funny how your brain works because I was on Fallon one time promoting the All-Star game, and I got
当你的声音处于悬而未决的状态时，你有没有担心过你的职业生涯就此结束了？是的，那一团糟，我把女儿们快折磨疯了，因为我早上开车送她们去上学时会说：“这样怎么样，这个听起来好点了吗？飞球飞向右外野，退后接住的是彼得森，这样就是两个出局了。这样怎么样？”我以为一切都完了，但声音只是慢慢恢复了。我能感觉到它在变好，虽然你听不出它在变好，但你的大脑运作方式真的很搞笑，因为我曾有一次上肥伦秀宣传全明星赛，
out of that appearance thinking, oh man, I totally got through that. I sounded great. And if I go back, if you Google me on Fallon's show in 2011, it's horror. I can't even watch it. And it's just funny that I was willing to kind of put myself out there and I didn't miss a game, I sounded horrible. The problem is when you have a paralyzed vocal cord, you can't hold air because it just escapes. And so you can't emote, you can't get loud, you can't, and so I'm trying to just hold
我录完那个节目出来后心想：哦，天呐，我总算撑过去了。我听起来太棒了。如果我回去——如果你在谷歌上搜2011年肥伦秀上的我——简直是一场灾难。我甚至没法看。真搞笑，我当时竟然愿意冒着那种风险，而且我没有错过任何一场比赛，虽然我听起来糟糕透顶。问题是，当你声带麻痹时，你无法保持气息，因为气流会直接漏掉。所以你无法表达情感，你无法提高音量，你无法……所以我只能尽量屏住呼吸，等待时机，从牙缝里挤出解说词，最终到了十月份声音终于恢复了，我真的很感激，因为医生曾告诉我如果三个月内不恢复就永远不会恢复了，而当时已经远远超过三个月了。
my breath, wait for the moment, squeak out of play by play call, and eventually it came back for October and it just, I was really thankful because doctors were telling me if it doesn't come back in three months, it's not coming back, and it was way over three months. Is your voice insured? I did for a while. I think it would be probably hard to insure after that, and it's not perfect. It's not what it was prior to this whole incident.
你的声音投保了吗？我曾投保过一段时间。我想在那之后大概很难投保了，而且它现在并不完美。它已经不是经历这一切之前的那个声音了。
If you're going to go back and do more treatments, you're still going to be put under with the tube down your throat? No. So that's the things. What little did I know? So I wrote about this, this is how my book worked. What's the name of the book, Joe? Book is called Lucky Bastard.
如果你打算回去做更多治疗，你还是会被麻醉然后喉咙里插管吗？不。所以这就是重点。我当时对此一无所知！所以我把这段写进书里了，我的书就是这么写的。这本书叫什么名字，乔？这本书叫《幸运儿》。
Lucky Bastard can be found wherever you like to buy your own books. It's on discount racks everywhere. Is he giving you a cut of his shit? What is this? You have a little range of your own books. Unbelievable. Make sure to tune in and watch Lego Masters Tuesdays on Fox. Can I do that now?
《幸运儿》可以在任何你喜欢买书的地方买到。到处都是打折书架。他分给你版税了吗？这是什么情况？你还有自己的一系列书。简直难以置信。确保收看周二在福克斯播出的《乐高大师》。我现在能做这个广告吗？
Yeah. Sure. Now I want to know why I'm still on the hair thing. Your dad was a really attractive, pretty hairless fella. When your colleagues, John Smoltz, got a beautiful head on him, not a ton of hair on it. What's the need? Let's stop the madness. Narcissism?
当然。现在我想知道为什么我们还在纠结头发的事。你爸爸是个非常迷人、几乎没怎么秃顶的帅哥。你的同事，约翰·斯莫尔茨，长着一颗漂亮的脑袋，上面其实没多少头发。到底图什么？停止这种疯狂吧。自恋吗？
Ego? No, what ego? You got a gorgeous head. You look good bald. Why don't you shave the whole goddamn thing? I know. I wouldn't. No, I wouldn't.
自我？不，什么自我？你长了一颗华丽的脑袋。你光头也很好看。你为什么不把整个该死的脑袋都剃光呢？我知道。我才不呢。不，我不会的。
Jason, listen to you. With all the hair you have on you, you're like a billionaire saying to somebody who doesn't have any money, like, why can't you be happy? You're alive. You should be happy. You're alive. That's right. It's a nice day outside.
杰森，听听你说的。凭你身上所有的头发，你就像一个亿万富翁对一个身无分文的人说：“你怎么就不能高兴点？你还活着。你应该高兴。你还活着。”没错。外面天气真好。
It's easy for you to say, motherfucker. You know? Look at that. It's going different directions. I know. If I had enough hair where pieces could go in different directions like that, it's just annoying. It looks like a little boy.
你当然说得轻松，混蛋。你知道吗？瞧瞧那个。它正朝不同的方向长呢。我知道。如果我有足够的头发让它们朝不同的方向乱翘，那只会让人心烦。看起来像个小男孩。
But here's the great news. His hair's got great roots because there's so much empty space below the skull for it to fight for the root. Well, that sounds like an insult. Okay. See? He doesn't even know. Oh, Lord.
但好消息是：他的头发有着极好的发根，因为头骨下方有那么多空闲空间供发根去争取养分。嗯，听起来像是在骂人。好吧。看吧？他自己甚至都不知道。哦，天呐。
I don't know. I can't answer anything other than I have since done another one for the first time. I did it like a couple months ago and I highly recommend it and it's not painful. So I know what I started to say. I didn't realize because I opened my book with this that my name was mud in the hair transplant world from these doctors because I talked about the barbaric pain that comes with it and they're like, you're driving people away, you know, the seven people that read your book.
我不知道。除了我最近又做了一次手术之外，我什么也回答不上来。我大概在几个月前刚做过，我强烈推荐，而且一点都不疼。所以，我知道我刚才想说什么了。我没有意识到——因为我的书一开头就写了这件事——我在植发界的声誉因为这些医生而彻底搞砸了，因为我谈到了随之而来的野蛮痛苦，他们说：“你在把人们吓跑，你知道的，那七个读你书的人。”
You're driving people away by talking about how awful the procedure is. And they're right because now it's simple. But you know, Joey, you bring up a boy. So the people in that world hate you. There are a lot of people who are gunning for you. It sounds like that. According to you. Who loves you?
你通过谈论这个手术有多可怕把人们吓跑了。他们说得对，因为现在手术很简单了。但你知道吗，乔伊，你提出了一个好问题。所以那个圈子里的人都很恨你。有很多人都在伺机对付你。听起来是这样的。据你所说。谁爱你？
Who loves you? My mommy. My mom loves me. I love you. Sean loves me. Thank you. Michelle. Michelle loves me most of the time when I'm not complaining about paying a dad for the
谁爱你？我妈妈。我妈爱我。我爱你在。肖恩爱我。谢谢你。米歇尔。米歇尔大部分时间都爱我，只要我不在第二次抱怨付爸爸……
second time around. Yeah. My daughters. Who would win in a fight between you and Aikman? Aikman. Yeah. Really? He's a tough, he's a big guy.
第二次。是的。我的女儿们。你和艾克曼打架谁会赢？艾克曼。是的。真的吗？他很强硬，他是个大块头。
Look at Aikman. He's got abs. He's got. Does he have abs? Muscles. Oh, he has abs. Yeah. He's in good shape.
看看艾克曼。他有腹肌。他有。他有腹肌吗？肌肉。哦，他有腹肌。是的。他身材保持得很好。
It's annoying. But my point is, should we have, should there be a battle? We can get some announcers. I'll take Michaels. I'll take Michaels. So you and Al Michaels, okay. This is, by the way, I can sell this to Showtime by. Nance.
这太烦人了。但我的意思是，我们应该来一场对决吗？我们可以找几个解说员。我选迈克尔斯。我选迈克尔斯。所以你和阿尔·迈克尔斯，好的。顺便说一句，我可以把这个卖给Showtime。南斯。
I'll take my chances with Nance. With Nance. Oh. Old Jimmy Nance has got a real sharp jab on him. Yeah. No, no. Talk to me about Nance a little bit. I'll, I'll hello friends him.
我押南斯会赢。押南斯。哦。老吉米·南斯有一记非常犀利的直拳。不，不。跟我聊聊南斯吧。我会对他“向朋友们问好”。
I'll hello friends. Jimmy's real folksy. He gets real folksy on you. But I love his style because he keeps it real casual and he keeps it right down here. And you'll be watching, they do the handoff. You'll, you're watching the golf on the, you know, on the Thursday or Friday or even on, on a Saturday morning. And then all of a sudden the, you know, they get to the network broadcast and all of a sudden
我会“向朋友们问好”。吉米非常接地气。他在你面前会变得非常接地气。但我喜欢他的风格，因为他保持得很随性，而且把音调压得很低。你正看着，他们完成了交接。你在星期四或星期五，甚至在星期六早上的高尔夫球赛上看着高尔夫。然后突然间，你知道的，他们连上了电视网直播，突然间
Nance and Sir Nick pop on real, real, like, like somebody just quietly let them in the back door. Before you know it, Nance is romancing the microphone. He's like, well, and Nick, tell me about Kepka. What are you doing? Oh, shit. Who let Nance in? And then making verbal love to his microphone.
南斯和尼克爵士突然冒出来，非常、非常自然，就像有人静静地让他们从后门进来一样。不知不觉中，南斯开始对麦克风进行浪漫的表白了。他说：“嗯，尼克，跟我讲讲科普卡。你在干什么？”哦，操。谁把南斯放进来的？然后对他的麦克风进行言语上的“做爱”。
I know you're right. He loves it. He's got it. He's got the gain on real high. Tremendous skill. He's got, he's got the game turned way up. So look, watch this. I'll just do this on my mic here.
我知道你说得对。他太喜欢了。他有这个。他把增益调得很高。巨大的技巧。他把游戏增益调得超级高。所以看，看着这个。我就在我的麦克风上这么做。
So you can turn the game way up so you can talk low and you don't have to give much of a voice. And here it comes. And now I'm Jim Nance. And here he comes for that walking, walking up the 18th. I want you to say, Will, I want you to hear this. Yeah. I want you to say just, but put a lot of time between all, I'm going to go for all four
所以你可以把增益调得很高，这样你就能低声说话，而不用发出太大的声音。然后它来了。现在我是吉米·南斯。他来了，走向第18洞。我想让你说，威尔，我想让你听听这个。是的。我想让你说，但是要在所有、我要说全部四个
words. Just a moment ago. Just a moment ago. Yeah. And then bam. My voice, so I'm going to keep my game on real high here. And my guy's going to be mad. But my voice over idol was this guy, Hal Reini.
词之间留出很多时间。就在刚才。就在刚才。是的。然后，砰。我的声音，所以我打算把增益调得很高。我的搭档会生气的。但我的配音偶像就是这个人，哈尔·雷尼。
And he used to do Perrier. You'll remember he's long since passed. But he'd go, there is the town in the middle of France. Where the water comes out. And it's a little above. And that is that Perrier. Oh, I love that guy. I love that.
他以前经常为巴黎水做广告。你会记得他已经去世很久了。但他会说：“那是法国中部的一个小镇。水从那里涌出。它略高于地面。这就是巴黎水。”哦，我太喜欢那个家伙了。我太喜欢了。
I'm going to turn myself down now. Joe, thank you. And please enjoy the rest of your five week vacation in Mexico. Yes. And stay away from crashing more weddings. Joe, thank you. You're a real champ for being here. Thanks, Joe.
我現在要把自己调小音量了。乔，谢谢你。请尽情享受你在墨西哥为期五周的剩余假期吧。是的。别再去搞砸别人的婚礼了。乔，谢谢你。你能来这里真是个真正的冠军。谢谢你，乔。
Nice to meet you. Thank you, buddy. Thanks, Will. Thanks, Sean. Thanks, Justin. Thank you for your wonderful callback. He brought it all the way back. Hashtag cold back.
很高兴认识你。谢谢你，伙计。谢谢你，威尔。谢谢你，肖恩。谢谢你，贾斯汀。谢谢你精彩的呼应。他一路呼应回来了。话题标签：呼应。
Thank you, Joe. Hopefully we'll see you soon in Los Angeles. Yes, that would be nice. Please hurry. Just a moment ago. Just a moment ago. Ago. Into the hole it goes.
谢谢你，乔。希望我们很快能在洛杉矶见到你。是的，那会很棒。请快点。就在刚才。就在刚才。刚才。球滚进洞里了。
Thank you, my friend. Thanks, buddy. Bye, pal. Bye. Oh, another nasty, unfriendly, non-talkative prick. Sean, do you, when you hear him talking about his relationship with his dad, does it make you wish that your dad took you to the track? With him?
谢谢你，我的朋友。谢谢你，伙计。再见，老兄。再见。哦，又是一个讨厌的、不友好的、不爱说话的混蛋。肖恩，当听他谈论他跟父亲的关系时，你会不会希望你爸爸也带你去赛马场？跟他一起？
Every day. And when we say track, we're talking about the dog track. Or highlight. Highlight was Tuesdays and Thursdays, right? Is he still with us, by the way? My dad? He is. Yeah, he's somewhere.
每天都去。当我们说赛马场时，我们指的是赛狗场。或者是回力球场。回力球是周二和周四，对吧？顺便问一句，他现在还在我们身边吗？我爸？还在。是的，他在某个地方。
What's his name? Quick. He's a big fan. He's a big fan. His name is Ron. Ron or Ronald? Yeah. Yeah.
他叫什么名字？快说。他是他的超级粉丝。他是他的超级粉丝。他叫罗恩。罗恩还是罗纳德？是的。是的。
Boy, that is a, let me tell you something. That is a dog track name right there. Okay. It would use Ronald for highlight, but Ron's definitely at the track. The double Windsor. By the way, how many times has he heard this in his life? Hey, Ron, who do you like in the fourth? He knows how to slam a door, doesn't he?
天呐，这名字，我跟你说个事。这绝对是个赛狗场的名字。好吧。打回力球时会用罗纳德，但罗恩绝对在赛狗场。双温莎结。顺便问一句，他这辈子听过多少次这句话？“嘿，罗恩，第四场你觉得谁能赢？”他很会摔门，对吧？
Wills on the ground. Come on back up. I don't know why he makes me laugh so much because it makes Sean laugh so much. I love it. You know, when he was saying about how he inspired him or when Joe was talking about how his dad inspired him, you know, we always, I used my dad leaving as kind of like every day you wake up and you think, I'll show you. Yeah.
威尔摔倒在地了。快起来。我不知道为什么他能让我笑得这么厉害，因为这让肖恩笑得太厉害了。我太喜欢了。你知道的，当他说到他是如何激励他的时候，或者当乔谈到他父亲是如何激励他的时候，你知道的，我们总是——我把我爸的离开当作一种动力，让你每天醒来都想：走着瞧。是的。
I saw you nodding when he said that though. Not nodding off. I saw you nod. I went like, yes. Yeah. No, no. I love that kind of talk. I didn't know he had a podcast called Daddy Issues and they just talk about all that stuff.
不过他这么说时我看到你在点头。不是打瞌睡。我看到你点头了。我当时想：对。是的。不，不。我喜欢这种谈话。我不知道他有个播客叫《恋父情结》，他们就在上面聊所有这些事情。
Yes. I would imagine. Did you talk about your dad? I think I did. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know why I can't remember the stuff that I do. Maybe because I'm just concentrating when I'm doing it.
是的。我猜是的。你们聊过你爸吗？我想我聊过。是的。我不知道。我不知道为什么我不记得我做过的事情。也许是因为我在做的时候只是在专注。
That's all right. We all remember. Will, go ahead. Take a shot real quick. I don't want to say anything. Nope. Okay. It'll come.
没关系。我们都记得。威尔，请说。快来一句。我不想说什么。不。好吧。会想起来的。
It'll come. We know why. There it is. We know why. Here it comes. And. No, I'm just because you're not in touch with yourself. Yeah.
会想起来的。我们知道为什么。就是这样。我们知道为什么。它来了。而且。不，我只是因为你没有和自己内心连结。是的。
That's why. It's down there somewhere. By the way, I'm not exactly completely in touch with myself either. So I'm, you know, glass houses over here. Well, I'm in touch with both of you. I don't know. And I'm in touch with you. Yeah.
这就是原因。它就在那底下的某处。顺便说一句，我也不是完全和自己内心连结。所以，你知道的，我这儿也是玻璃房子。好吧，我跟你们俩都有连结。我不知道。而且我跟你有连结。是的。
Sean, you are, you're pretty in touch with yourself. You've been doing a lot of work. I mean it. Oh, thank you. You know, you do a lot of work on this stuff. And I, I, I respect, I totally respect that. I think it's awesome the way that you do that you've, that's become an important part of your life.
肖恩，你、你跟自己的内心连结得挺紧密的。你做了很多自我觉察的工作。我是认真的。哦，谢谢你。你知道的，你在这些方面做了很多工作。而且我、我尊重，我完全尊重这一点。我觉得你所做的那种方式太棒了，这已经成为你生活中的重要部分。
Thank you. Yeah. No, I, I, I try to be self aware at 24 hours a day. Are you currently in therapy? Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh God. Once a week.
谢谢你。是的。不，我、我努力做到每天24小时都有自我觉察。你目前在做心理治疗吗？对。哦，是的。哦，天呐。每周一次。
Once a week. Yeah. Standing appointment. Standing appointment. 1230 Monday. Yeah. Come on. Yeah.
每周一次。是的。固定预约。固定预约。周一中午12点半。得了吧。是的。
I'm not kidding. God, I wish I could get on a routine. You know, therapists have like a punch card. You're on a fucking routine. Dude, you're on a routine. You're on fucking routine. But it would be good for me to get into a routine. Either weekly or.
我没开玩笑。天呐，我希望能进入一种规律。你知道治疗师就像有打卡卡片一样。你有个他妈的规律。老兄，你有规律。你他妈的有规律。但建立一种规律对我有好处。无论是每周一次还是……
Or by monthly. You can smell me leading into it. I smell that too. Yeah, that was really good. Old fish. Bye. Smart. Yes.
或者每两个月一次。你能闻到我正往那方面引。我也闻到了。是的，那真的很好。老鱼。再见。聪明。是的。
Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes.
聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。
Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Yes. Yes. Smart. Yes.
聪明。是的。聪明。是的。是的。是的。聪明。是的。
Yeah. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart.
是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. Well, we'll be out in a week where you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts, or by subscribing to Wondery Plus. plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。聪明。是的。好吧，我们会在一周内回归，你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提早收听，也可以通过在苹果播客或汪迪App上订阅汪迪Plus来提早收听并免除广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。